[Applause]
[Music]
okay thanks for coming thanks for
interaction so this is jaunt work with a
bunch of students on e quando fee you
can walk Jerry Thomas
Hoshi from Stanford Princeton Berkeley
and and the wheel chopper Dario and yang
donggeun I guess senior people they are
more famous so I save the space for the
students for the pictures okay and I'm
coming out from Stanford
so I guess so this laughs research you
know starts with you know the kind of
concern of sample efficiency at least
for me you know it starts from the
sample efficiency concern about RL so I
guess you know you probably have heard
of you know all the successful
applications of RL to for example
learning goes you learning you know
robotic arms and probably not that
successful applications of learning
self-driving cars I guess you know the
kind of though the fundamental idea I
guess you know of RL in some sense is
twelve sand arrows so in some sense the
kind of like pretty much all our
algorithms have this come two steps you
know first you twice on current strategy
and crack some feedbacks and then use
the feedbacks to improve the strategy
and you repeat this you know the first
step and and so and so forth so I guess
the question is how many times we have
to try this strategy and collect
feedbacks and for those you know we know
that you know if we use millions of
games to try so then we can learn the
the goal and this sounds fun because all
of these trials are in computers and you
have you know enough machines like deep
mind how Google so then we are happy and
we just have to wait for probably a few
weeks you know or maybe even less than
that and if you think about millions of
games probably it's kind of not that
crazy because probably if you think
about human being playing goes in the
history probably you know we learn how
to play go from millions of games and
however Ephrem you know we talk about
you know learning robotic arms you know
robotics ourself coming
with trials then it's a bit more kind of
questionable with millions millions of
trials because there are kind of fiscal
constraints you know maybe after a
million of 12 you're awake I'm already
kind of like we're all or it takes so
long time because you cannot see be
doubt this by just having more GPU
compute so so I guess the the main well
the main question you know we are
considering here is that how do we
reduce an amount of trials the amount of
samples for you know reinforcement
learning I guess I'm going to talk about
in a few ideas that try to kind of like
a reduce the amount of samples so
model-based reinforced Mirnyi
I'm gonna define what it is and
imitation learning from expert
demonstrations and and multitask or
lifelong continue or reinforcement
learning and I guess just for
completeness let me also mention other
can five years that I'm aware of that
can be potentially used reduce the
number of 12 in RL for example
hierarchical are all these are you know
ideas that can they confuse the
structure of the policy the hierarchical
structure of the policy on to reduce the
central complexity or maybe if you're
trails are much safer then you can allow
helping of much more trials so I guess
you know the those kind of points in
blue are what I'm going to talk about so
I'm going to start with some of the back
ones terminologies just in case some of
you are not very familiar with you
enforcement earning this is just one
slide if you're experts bear with me for
one slide
I guess I'm mostly just going to define
reinforce learning in a continuous state
space and with deterministic dynamics
and determines the policy so this is the
setting we we are interesting so I guess
so well the feature of reinforced
morning is that there is a time you know
factor there so this is about sequential
decision making so we have to you know
make actions
decide actions over time so there's a
time component so T is from 0 to capital
T and often we think of captivity as
approximately infinite so sometimes we
just have our infinite horizon so and
there's this notion of state and action
a state in our case is a high
dimensional vector here Rd and action is
also high
mr. bacteria archaea and the guys you
know for robotic applications you can
think of the state as the physical
states [ __ ] up the location of arm the
policy of arms and no and other can
physical states and action could be the
desired movement for you know different
kind of joints of the arms and there's
an unknown dynamics or sometimes we call
it environment i'm star so this
environment is all dynamics is
describing what will happen in the
future so so it takes in two arguments
st the carbon stake and iet the current
action and it will return the next state
st plus one and often this is considered
to be unknown because we don't really
know how to exactly model for example
what the robotic arm is gonna do so and
there's a notion of trajectory so here
are one trajectory so basically we just
apply a sequence of actions to the
states and we got you know a sequence of
states so often for at least for this
talk we considered that the initial
state is joining from some distribution
these sub s 0 and then we apply sequence
actions and each time you know apply
action is zero and you apply the unknown
dynamics and you kind of serve as one
and they're applying action a1 and we
observe as to so and so forth there's
this notion of policy this is something
we want to learn we want to know how to
control on the system to to get into a
desired state so our policy is a
function that map's the state to the
actions so in this case you know if you
apply some policy from starting points
as 0 then basically you know and the
first step we are going to apply PI of s
0 this is the action we compute from s 0
and then we got s 1 and they apply PI of
s 1 we got s 2 and so on and so forth so
I guess so
another important thing about reinforced
learning is the the reward this is
something no this is the real thing that
kind of helped us to learn so the
definition of reward is just a function
that map's the current state and action
to a real number so so basically you
just have a thumb up thumb down pretty
much at every step and and use and would
really care about is that the total
expected pay
of our policy so so we start from some
random state s0 joining from the
distribution of s 0 T sub s 0 and I know
look at the the total expected payoff in
the future you know we can take a sum
over you know key steps or sum over
infinite number of steps the exact
details probably don't matter for this
talk and I'm going to define the value
of the total expected total payoff to be
be PI here so we pass a real number is
the expectation of the total payoff of
running the policy so here all the
actions are actually you know the
corresponding output of the policy on
the the corresponding state alright so
this is just a very short introduction
of reinforcement learning and definition
of notations and so let me move on to
the the main idea of model-based
reinforcement learning so I guess so
there's no kind of like I guess so kind
of like a unique or like a rigorous
definition of model-based reinforce
learning you know roughly speaking you
can consider something like model-based
or evil if you learn the dynamics
I'm star somewhat explicitly so I guess
a standard model based reinforce
learning algorithm look like this so we
repeat you know between several steps we
alternate you know several steps so the
first step is that we sample some
trajectories from the real environment
I'm star this is kind of like a you
drive the car you know you like the you
know the software to drop the car in the
street and you know clock the
experiences and and you get to this kind
of like uh trajectories here I'm going
to have one trajectory but in reality
you get a lot of trajectories from
different initialization or different in
eco states so we get all of these
structures and then we'll learn a
dynamical model or dynamics using
existing trajectories and and the way to
learn it is that we you know pretty much
this fatal model talks down for the
model is parameterized by you much work
so we just want to find a model M such
that this model will predict the correct
next state given the the current state
and an action
so here the sum is over all the possible
steps and also all the
virtual actors which I'm not writing in
specific you so and often people use you
know L 2 norm square as the last
function I'll discuss you know whether
this is the right loss function in
moment so and the third step is that
given we have such a learned dynamics
and we are going to find a good policy
for learn dynamics app so and you know
and this I think the important feature
of this step is that this is step that
is purely done in computer so so there
are dynamics you know is parameterize by
some networks and you can simulate your
dynamics you can potentially even
compute gradients and and this you know
step it doesn't matter what you do it
doesn't cost any real samples so you
don't have to you know collect in a real
samples and and in for our you know
purpose you know we just want to
minimize the number of real samples from
the real environment we want to use so
this step doesn't count towards any cost
so so so pretty much you know you can
use any our algorithm model frayed or
model base you know whatever you like
for for this step and and there's no
sample cost so and actually in practice
you know what people do is that people
often use a good model free algorithm
like T RPO
policy gradient for this death even
though it's not very efficient but it
because these are all no samples from
the real environment so we don't we are
fine with it
so guys you know if this algorithm
starts in all the complicated you know
at first I think that's what I felt I
think there's a there's a way to make an
analogy I guess that's how I kind of
started to understand it Oh
two years ago so so in some sense this
the third step is kind of like you
planned a vacation at home
suppose you're suppose you want to go to
a kind of Hawaii and you have to have
vacations and and the third step is
really just you planned a vacation or
imagination in some sense the first step
is kind of like you really go and enjoy
and explore different of restaurants for
example and and then you keep notes on
the good restaurants and so that's the
next step
suppose you want to go to Hawaii again
then you know you know how to how to
plan ahead much better at home so you
can co-op those restaurants that are
very busy for example in advance to have
a have a have a reservation so
and you can you know iterate between the
steps and after probably a few
iterations you are expert about going
about Hawaii anyway okay so I guess some
this is the general model based ro
algorithm and I guess you know I'm a
theoretician and the main purpose of
this you know this work is to kind of
like analyze some of these deep
model-based ro algorithm and wisdom who
is kind of like the the motivation of
kind of like analyzing them and finding
something new probably that can be
practically relevant and implement it so
I guess you know at a high level the
challenge is you know as you can imagine
are that you know this is hard mental
state and action space and and then the
dynamics are nonlinear and the policy
are all nonlinear parameterize many much
work see that you find in step 3 not
necessarily for example you may want to
kind of ID for example explorations yes
so this is just a very high-level kind
of framework for model-based are so and
actually empirically we do a lot of
exploration so when we try in the next
in step one so I guess so so so these
are kind of like the the general kind of
like challenges you know as you can
imagine for for reinforcement learning
of know for pretty much you know any
other places where we use you know big
models you know deep networks and they
want to analyze the performance I guess
you know
so here two mics okay so so the new art
works you know in sometimes it creates
two tulu challenges so what is
computational because you know we don't
know how to optimize you know a non
convex function you know from the
artworks so in some times this
competition or problem is not what we
are trying to kind of address here
because if you want to address the
computational problem maybe the first
thing we should do is to do super
learning because there we still don't
know how to analyze the the optimization
for networks so so in some sense we are
kind of trying to address the
the distal questions here created by
jointly by the hydro state space and
nonlinear dynamics so so I guess the
goal is that we want to have analyzed
more provable algorithms with Pournami
number of samples in dimension and and
we are kind of like allowing yourself to
assume some computational oracles folks
up you can solve certain half non convex
functions or instances I guess just to
briefly summarize some of the prior work
along a space of model-based RL I guess
done there is a a long line of research
about you know the finite state space
case where the state space is finite and
action space is also finite and and
recently there are quite a few works you
know for example especially and all here
from Barracks group about you know how
to analyze them this comes model based
algorithms for linear dynamics
especially io q are the linear quadratic
regulator where the dynamics is linear
and a reward function is quadratic
actually we got a lot of inspirations
from that paper and also they are kind
of simple complex the result where for
model-based reinforcement in recently
where you assume that you can distinct
ties the state space you know so you
don't completely don't care about you
know whether the algorithm is
implementable so you just say I'm going
to have a exponential time algorithm by
this crisis in the state space but I
want to analyze the sample complexity so
here I guess the difference between our
kind of go from that paper is that we do
want to analyze some algorithm that can
be somewhat implementable in reality
even though you again we have to assume
some competition of Oracle's ok so I
guess so the the first issue we face you
know when we try to kind of analyze this
kind of smaller base our algorithm is
that the learn dynamics are not accurate
enough for those days
and seen in the Qin attractors so I
guess let me illustrate this you know
figure so suppose you know this kind of
training trajectories you have a robot
and and you collect you know you read
some policy and you clock this kind of
trajectories you know these are three
trajectories and each of them consists
of four steps
and and these are collected on a real
you know dynamics and and you learn some
dynamical model and anyone to predict
you know what happens in the future
right so with the with the learned that
if no model and it turns out that you
know thing if you do it in practice and
so and actually it's not surprising
because you know because of the power of
super learning if you predict the
trajectory using the same state and the
same policy then you can predict you
reasonably well so so if the the initial
state and the policy are the same you
know in a test time then you know you
can predict very well just because of
the power of super learning however if
you try some different policy for
example you try to you know move left
and all right so you take actions that
are moving left and then because these
are part of the space that have not been
visited by the training algorithm the
Cheney introductory then because all of
these are nonlinear models and they
don't extrapolate very well for the
other part of the space so we really
test it on other kind of policies you
can have you know much much bigger error
in terms of prediction so so in some
sense you know this is kind of like a no
issue about you know exploitation and
exploration so you have to click kind of
explore in some sense you do some
exploitation in some sense in a sense
that we should try to go to places that
dynamic is kind of certain so we want to
go to those places where we have visited
so that we know what happens in the
future on the other hand you know you
don't cannot kind of just ignore this
entire space you know just because you
have never visited them and you are not
certain because it's possible that those
a part of the space contains interesting
rewards so that's why we also have to
kind of have explorations we have to
improve the certainty of the model by
trying diverse policies we have to kind
of go there at some point tries to
collect you know our feedbacks and you
know observations from those kind of
policies so access the class idea to
deal with this optimism in the face of
uncertainty
it's called autism in the face of
uncertainty so the idea is that you can
send productions from so so this is kind
of a ok uh iterative algorithm a kind of
a mighta algorithm so the first step is
to say
so we sample trajectories from real
dynamics using the current policy and
then in a second step we are going to
optimize the policy and the dynamics in
a joint way in the sense that we
optimize this you know beep I am so I
haven't given a definition of this so we
Pam you know as you can imagine is used
to denote that it's easy to denote the
payoff of the policy pie on a learned
dynamic dynamics app so we optimize the
the virtual payoff in on a virtual model
over both the policy dynamics with the
constraint that the dynamics has to be
consistent with the existing
trajectories you have seen so and you
know actually a lot of you know existing
model-based our algorithm in a discreet
state space follows this kind of like
calm metal IR algorithm so so this you
know in some sense this kind of like a
offed wisdom in the face of uncertainty
allows us to explore a policy if it is
good for some reasonable dynamics right
so you try some policy as long as this
policy is good and a certain model as
long as this model is obviously
consistent with them with all the
existing trajectories then you consider
this model is you know is a good choice
it's a potential choice and if the
policy gives you very good reward on
that dynamics and you can see that's a
good policy so so to try that policy in
the next stage by collecting more
trajectories so I guess some are for so
for for this quiz state space this is
really just means that you have a
confidence interval for the parameter
super actually that's the okay that's
the next two questions for this quiz
space you know to answer a question this
is just a confidence interval for the
parameters and and for us you know for
linear models you can do the same thing
ellipsoid but for nonlinear models we
don't really know how to really are
express that so express the constraint
here
because you know if you do confidence
intervals for the parameter space it
does really make sense there's a lot of
permutation environments and even model
that there's probably still other
environments and it's anyway it's very
hard to build a confidence interval so
and and another kind of like a almost
the same question you know is how do we
even measure the consistency even you
can build a confidence interval you have
some kind of ways to match the
consistency but you need to have some
ways to measure the consistency or in
other words you know this relates to the
question how do we measure the errors of
the learn dynamics and I'd like to argue
that you know to measure this you know
it's kind of tricky because even the
same prediction laws you know if you say
use our two laws could you know mean
very differently for different states
and different actions so here is a
examples you have this you know very
beautiful view here and the suppose I'm
a robot
standing on the top of the mountain and
I suppose the robot is trying to decide
whether it should go left and go right
right so so there are two possible
actions going left and going right and
and we are doing model-based RL so
basically the robot is kind of imagining
what will happen in the future using its
own dynamical model in his hat in his
hat and and what he so basically what
happens is that you know photo for the
action to the left you know for the
right for the right action you have to
be very very accurate about your
prediction because if you make any error
you are kind of risking you know to kind
of fall off the cliff right so but for
the action to the left the the
prediction could be much less test if
you know you can be much less sensitive
about the prediction error because you
know it doesn't really matter what you
know exactly we predict you know it's
still kind of safe under the reward
probably are very very similar so so I
guess you know in some sense these
saying that you know the the ideal
prediction loss will depends on the
other particular state and problem
particular action and maybe also in
depends on a particular directions of
the of the state you want to predict
right so here in this directions you
should be more sensitive and the other
directions you could be less sensitive
are you so I think I'm more interesting
on the second one even though the first
one is also interesting thing to pursue
so for the fall for us you know we just
say we have a backpacking you know you
can help you know in some pose anger and
the way that we can have a guarantee
after learn you know using from the so
okay cool so you know yeah okay so I
guess you know the so what would be a
good way to measure the loss the error
for the model so I guess the our idea is
that you know ideally in some sense also
naive like the ideal loss for for the
model M should be the error of
predicting the future payoff using app
because this is really how you use the
model to do so you want to use the model
to predict the future payoff so that you
can plan accordingly
and so in some sense you know we care
about the difference between the virtual
payoff BPM this is the total payoff on a
scale dynamics of policy PI and the real
payoff on the other two dynamics of
course this is something you cannot you
know measure or you cannot kind of
access because if you can access this
and you can access the virtual rewards
then you can actually get the real you
know total payoff so so so when we to
get around this is that you know we can
say oh I care about the design you know
harbor bound of this idea loss function
that I really care about and I want to
use this upper bound as a surrogate loss
or a consistent measure for for my for
my model so so supposed to have upper
bound like this you know let's call it B
of M PI suppose I have such upper bounds
then I can use this upper bound to to
measure the performance of the model app
of course I want you know every bound to
be as tight as possible and and if I'm
such a talked about I can say a dynamic
and has low loss or in other words it's
consistent with the existing
trajectories existing data if and can
predict a reward with some kind of like
all of the real reward with some error
upper bound like en hi and we are bound
to be as small as possible so so in some
sense this is a consistent score or
consistent measure with only a scalar
right so this is the only thing that you
care about as a consistent measure and
going back to the kind of like the are
the optimism in the face of uncertainty
framework so just M is consistent with
the existing trajectories we can
translate to you know just saying the
upper bound of this you know discrepancy
measure between a real reward and real
proto payoff and the virtual total
payoff is less than absolute what is the
policy policy pi is a variable here in
my optimization so I won that inequality
the upper bound to be hold for every
policy PI so that I can optimize over
policy PI and still hold that so the
constraint is over every part it's a
policy file or just the policy policy
owner in here is only over the the model
and and both actually both pine IMR
variables and the constraint is just
this and you optimizing over both PI and
I'm
so in some sense this is a confidence
region so if you think about you know
the constraint here is a continent
region for M but which depends on PI and
also depends on reward function right so
it depends on what reward function you
are using your confidence building will
becomes no bigger or smaller for example
if your with reward function is
completely boring say the count the
reward is always always 1 then the
confidence region in this case would be
I think that because you know the upper
bound is always 0 so you don't have any
constraint actually
so and next up we are going to do is
that just to make it this little bit
simpler and you grab our you know final
algorithm so we're going to absorb this
constraint into the into the objective
just because they are actually talking
about the same thing they are all on the
scale of the reward and actually this is
actually expected about the difference
between the reward of the real reward
and and the virtual reward so I guess
though this is the the final might
algorithm we use that we can analyze so
there are two steps you know you know is
in this loop so so we sandwich director
is using some current policy pi k k is
my each rate for the policy and we build
this upper bound deeper I'm I'm kind of
secretly kind of adding this subscript I
K to indicate that this upper bound
depends on the current policy so forth
different policy you can build different
upper bound and it have a such error
bound then you can do this you know
iteratively optimism in the face of
uncertainty we can optimize this you
know V power minus the the difference of
the reward so actually you can realize
that you know because V is the upper
bound of the differences between V Prime
and V prime star actually the difference
between them is a lower bound of the of
the reward will reward the reward beep
hi I'm star the real total payoff so I
guess I'm going to find this lower bound
I've helped M high so for future use so
see we can prove here is that we assume
the model family contains the two
dynamics
M star and and assume that the inner
that this optimization is solvable so
how do we solve that we can use
although free our algorithm so actually
even though you're optimizing over post
pine I am you can actually view this as
a standard our algorithm so you can view
both I'm and PI actually ice policy this
is a there's a reduction there which is
a little bit tricky which I'm not going
to detail I'll go into detail but
generally you can view this as on
another algorithm and you can use model
free ara to solve it so basically the
assumption that in the optimization
solvable is pretty much equivalent to on
that there's our algorithm that we can
um there's a this this we can solve this
RL problem using model free RL and we if
I have all of these assumptions then we
can assume we can show that this
algorithm will have monotone increase
monotone increase performance so the the
the real total payoff we PI K I'm star
it's gonna increase monotonically and
and the final reward will converge to a
local maximum of the real total payoff
and we can also show that this algorithm
have polynomial sample complexity just
because all of this you know suppose all
of these you know models and policies
are parametric eyes by polynomial size
networks and that's a great question so
this doesn't corresponds to a known
algorithm in a linear quadratic case so
so we thought about this a little bit at
some point it's a little tricky because
certainly this is not something crazy so
the this this one here the upper bound
is kind of like a lot of fancy version
of the of the confidence interval but
not exactly because in fact how do you
have the upper bound so so I was
thinking about using this for linear
quadratic regulator to get something
better that's something we couldn't get
and now QR is a little bit tricky
because there's a bellowing knob issue
so actually like if you you know if you
don't do it you know like so it's very
easy to kind of like make it blow up
because if you use the wrong policy so
so in some tricky actually sometimes
down in a moment
better than lqr in that sense because
nonlinear models you can assume that you
never it's a scalar so you here so I
didn't put the conifer here so we want
it to be true for every policy so so I
kind of like yes this is this might be
confusing so this is not a value
function this is the expected value
function expected over random in
acoustics cycle abusing the notation a
little bit here this reduction we use
the deterministic dynamic so so I think
I turn effect and use the deterministic
then I'm expect together are abound I
think we only know how to do it kind of
sensible are bound we only know how to
do it for deterministic and others
all right so I guess just to help a very
toy illustration of this algorithm so we
have this you know real total payoff
this is a function of Pi so and we are
building this kind of like iterative
lower bound for this real total tail and
you are maximizing the lower bound
actually up to the max matching or twice
over the twice of the lower bound and
also over the the policy is true for a
single distribution over there zero when
you fix the distribution of s feel right
way to optimize over the way you choose
this Devo YouTube you could choose their
own guess 0 yes so so I guess the short
answer is that term arm we we are
considering the situation where the
video is given to you so you can sample
you know from the initial distribution
oh I haven't thought too much about what
if it is not given okay
so I guess um okay I don't have much
time so I guess you know just - okay so
so so okay so so I have told you that -
no this is the key thing that we are
looking for work so we also have upper
bounds for the differences between the
total payoffs of the virtual payoff the
real pale and and how do we have Aquabot
if you have a coupon we have the
algorithm and the convergence and so
here is a time and attempt to get an
upper bound so this error bound is you
know let me kind of parse it for you so
I guess so on the right hand side we
have expectation and I first see what's
inside expectation so first of all I'm
kind of introducing this value function
now now also by abusing the notation
roll up but if I have my PI manage if
actually as a value a function it's a
function of state as so this is the
total payoff of the policy and on the
next I'm starting from state s so this
is the standard value of function and
and the notation V Prime I used before
is the expected value over an initial
distribution so so with this value of
function so in some sense this value of
function of course is the central object
in your post burning so the the idea is
that this is a this is function that
describes how good your state is right
so if the value of function is high that
means that you should go to that state
and the state is kind of like good and
and otherwise the other state is not you
know worth waiting and and here was
instant expectation is really I guess I
plan is so okay maybe let me also
explain what I say an esper me so I say
s prime is a shorthand for st etienne SD
plus 1 so as the na TR the inputs of the
technical model IC plasma is the the
predict the next state you see as though
as the output of the dynamic model so
here in some sense this one was instead
expectation is evaluation is a metric
for evaluating how good the model M is
so basically you look at you know what
MSA is this is what you predict as the
next state and you look at what the real
next day is as prime and you measure
there
difference I buy the the difference
between the corresponding value
functions at these two states right so
if this value functions for example is
identity then you can have you know just
the root there's no difference between
these two states but actually we are not
matching there all this difference
between them we are measuring the
difference between the value functions
of them so it's the distribution that
you see when you started at zero and
following star so this means that you
get this kind of like a couple by using
policy pi starting from s 0 and and on
the time star another with an axe so so
that's why here I'm saying that the
problem with this is that this is a good
upper bound this is approved upper bound
the proof is pretty simple it's just a
telescoping sum but the issue is that
they require samples from the
environment I'm star the real
environment to ask me the loss so if you
do this you know and for every PI you
have to do it again so if you do this
then you lose the point because you know
even just to optimize over this bound
and upper bound
you have to resample from the real
environment so so here is improve
dilemma that can that tries to solve
this issue so what we do here is that we
say suppose there's a reference policy
this is probably the this is actually
the the previous policy that you are
using so suppose there is a reference
policy and and now you can change this
expectation the institution for this
expectation to be the stays from the
reference policy and I'm a star and I'm
star so and and if this is the case and
and of course you know we have to
restrict our policy now so pi is
somewhat close to a reference PI we
cannot move too far too far away and now
we can define this as the upper bound so
it's a are abound photos for you know
that depends on the reference policy and
also the upper bound only fold host only
hold for policy PI that is close to PI
right so but the good thing is that now
the other one can be reused if PI
doesn't change too much so you can
restrict how much the PI is changing
we're using this you know upper bar so
and also another point here is that it's
Arabic we can reproduce the upper bound
we can recover the non bass the loss
from this upper bound either you know
even looser upper bound of if you
believe that the value function beep I
am is ellipsis respect to some norm
right so if me Pam is not Justin we can
see that this you know what is an
expectation it's bounded by the Royal
distance between I'm I say and as Prime
and this recovers you know the norm
based loss function so this is what your
sample from so you you this is a this
corresponds to us the step where you
sample trajectories from the real
environment but you want to do it many
times
that's why you don't want to use all the
different policies to sample so you want
to use the fixed policy in some test at
each iteration so I guess so when your
interesting point here is that if you
believe in this then there's no square
here in the in the loss function so you
only have to for example if you this is
normal I'll true then you only have L 2
norm instead of L 2 norm square and this
is actually a very helpful or empirical
a
so that means KL divergence excuse me
but you could have been square loss but
if you go back once time all theory and
also apply is this square so you have
Clark but you nobody P Square yes but I
guess II expectation or you know either
you don't have the ready no you have a
loose bond I guess you know but I guess
okay even you have square here and spark
here that's a you have to take a square
root right because this is finally you
don't have square here right so you all
know who only have other bound on a
difference but now the different square
right so yeah anyway I think the scale
tells you that you shouldn't have the
square
ok so I guess so I probably have like
five minutes so I guess it sounds like
apt escaped what's the second part of
the talk so but let me kind of finish
this one you know I guess so
so here are some kind of demonstrations
so okay so oh yeah
so I forgot to mention this so so this
inspires you know this kind of like oh
this this way of think about this you
know one kind of like inspiration comes
from not using square and there are some
other inspirations for example we use
stock as minions and to optimize our
objective but we kind of like ignore the
optimism so so if you do a CD with our
objective and with l2 loss not l2 square
and ignoring the optimism you're gonna
have a at least implementable algorithm
to try experimental e and this is some
demonstration of the algorithm so so I
guess what I show on the left hand side
so first of all the real environment
here is the Maluku environment so
because we don't want to deal with the
robot you know with all of this you know
you know I stand my lab that I have a
robot and this is the simplest way to to
run experiments so the real environment
is the Mojo Co and the stimulating
environment is the new much work right
so we use too much work to learn a more
joking environment and to see how many
samples we need to learn that
environment and a lot of hand side this
is what the learn dynamics you know
predicts and at iteration 10 so we have
this iteration number and you see the
policy is not great and it predicts that
the robot will fall and you can see that
actually the prediction is not correct
because in a real environment of course
it's still false but it's false in a
different way so so the prediction is
not correct and at each iteration 20 I
guess the same thing
I guess the interesting thing here is
that actually the prediction is not even
physically bad are valid because the
food is under the ground which is not
physically valid so and of course we can
imagine that the real reality does
something different and just a fast
forward you know to iteration 210 so now
we can show this together
you can see actually the model is very
good the dynamics is very good in terms
of predicting and also the policy is
very good in terms of we know of
succeeding the the task
okay so I guess we have some kind of
like cognitively um you know evaluations
you're comparing with the benchmark
tasks in mojo Co there's all different
kind of black environments humanoid is
what I showed before and other
environments and we can outperform fire
work zone with what many of your samples
have committed and I guess so this I'm
not sure but you can see so there is a
black line here which indicates the
optimal actually is a surrogate for the
optimal rewards so this is the reward
you can get get with ten million steps
of model free algorithms and we can kind
of like a bit diet in 1 million step
okay so I guess so I don't have any time
so I guess I would just quickly go
through some of the other things very
very quickly so I guess we have some
follow-up on model based money tasks are
off so the idea is that you can solve
multiple tasks then you can amortize
those sample costs so because we have
many many tasks and each they share the
dynamics so the sample cost that can be
amortized and even reduced and I guess
there's the entire part about imitation
learning which also uses some of these
ideas kind of like model based idea but
with some other kind of ideas I would
skip all of them like I just just jump
to the conclusion
so I guess so what so I have discussed
you know was that you know we have
convergence guarantees for Myrtle night
our model based our algorithm and and
well if the key component is that we
want to have a reward aware loss
function for the learning the dynamics
learning the dynamics or in other words
we'll have a good excellently measure
you know only with the single scalar for
measuring the uncertainty of the
dynamics and we have a much simplified
instantiation of the matter algorithm
called SL Bo which seems to work pretty
well in practice I guess would have been
talked about was model-based by a test
arrow and some imitation learning on
learning self correctable policies by uh
you know learning certain kind of by
apologies okay so in just a quick list
of open questions I guess you know they
are you know this is all empirically I
think the fascinating part of this kind
of like a research is that empirically a
lot of these ideas don't work that well
in practice and they're they're moved to
improve both from the theoretical side
and also the empirical side for example
how do we empirically leverage the
optimism in model-based RL so our
algorithms theoretical rhythm use a
pencil but but actually empirically we
don't find it to be very useful it
doesn't hurt that much but it doesn't
seems to be useful and how do we
customize our algorithm for particular
environments so this upper bound we have
a generic design of our bound and we
have a simplification based on our norms
but whether we can have something in
between when you have kind of
complicated you know environments which
doesn't have Lipsius value function how
we have some kind of reasonable are
bound in between that can be you know
optimized and how do we apply the ademco
models to other settings so learning
that and kimonos to other settings for
example hierarchical arrow or other type
of me know our algorithms
pushes for some physical systems where
you have the system dynamics problem how
do you compare the performance of the
part of this model based RLP more
classic problems such as variations of
common yeah so I guess so first of all
I'm not an expert
it's especially in robotics so my
understanding is that still in many
cases if you kind of like use the
physical in your prior knowledge to
design them that em come out often then
in many cases you know at least you can
have much fewer samples because together
dynamical model the dynamics you don't
have to know use samples to learn them
so but if you give me you know enough
samples them model-based are all even
model free are can you know outperform
the kind of like the physical prior
knowledge so so I guess you know there's
also kind of like an ongoing direction
that tries to use the existing prior
knowledge together which much works for
camp you can use the match works to
learn a residual between the the
physical a design a dynamical model with
which the real dynamic model and so I
thought the vapor from venorex group
with exactly arguing the opposite but if
you consider the simplest
compute the optimal policy in +4 then
you could reinforcement learning so
there wasn't he was arrogant but there
wasn't an example I'm not entirely sure
about interpretation but I don't
disagree but that guy's there is a
there's a slight difference here even um
you know I completely agree with what
you said
so for nonlinear models so I hope you
are the leading and model is in some
sense very easy to learn because you
only need ten you need you only need the
different actions in different
directions pretty much to learn maybe
okay okay so basically you need the
state space to be the the you need some
kind of diverse policy to extract to
explore different directions and then
you can learn the dynamics and here it's
kind of much more subtle when you have
nonlinear dynamics because for example
for linear dynamics you can use random
actions to learn the dynamics and here
you know for example human noise if you
use random action and you get some new
data should actually from random action
you're going to learn very very poor
dynamics so you have to do this
iterative steps to learn the dynamics
and optimize the policy and learn it an
external force I can chat offline
probably amore so maybe let's move the
discussion offline so now we have a
break until 11:00
[Applause]